vous les filles êtes des problèmes vous êtes le genre de
filles qui créent des problèmes si une
femme mariée devait créer des problèmes alors au
moins son mari est responsable d'elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce bâtiment n'est pas adapté aux
célibataires  ne le
donnez qu'aux deux familles et dans leur
définition, la famille est un homme, une femme et des
enfants, dans certains cas, même deux sœurs
vivant ensemble ou un frère et une sœur
vivant ensemble ne sont pas considérés comme une famille,
ils pensent qu'avec la
femme célibataire vient un peu de
drame qu'ils pourraient sortir avec quelqu'un avec qui ils pourraient
avoir des garçons, ils pourraient être vous savez
et quelqu'un m'a en fait dit que
nous avons eu des cas de call-girls vous
savez que vous ne devriez pas nous ne voulons pas que des
personnes étranges viennent dans le bâtiment et ainsi  vous
savez assurez-vous que vous savez que vous
resterez bien dans vos limites comme je l'ai
dit que quelqu'un a dit qu'il dira
au gardien de garder un œil sur vos
invités qui vient et pourquoi mais
le plus drôle en fait n  Ce qui est drôle, c'est que
la chose la plus dégoûtante que j'aie jamais
entendue, c'est que vous, les filles, tombez amoureuses
de garçons au hasard et quand ça ne
marche pas, vous vous suicidez et cela
rend notre immeuble moins viable car vous
savez et les taux de propriété vont  vers le bas
[Musique]